SETH LADD: Welcome.
We are live from the Google
I/O floor here with the
co-founders and engineers on the
Dart project, Kasper Lund
and Lars Bak.
Thank you guys for joining us.
My name is Seth Ladd, I'm a
developer advocate on the Dart
project and today we're going
to learn all about Dart.
So thanks guys.
First we should talk,
Lars, what is Dart?
And what can you do with it?
LARS BAK: Well, Dart is
a new programming
language and a platform.
It includes libraries and
programming tools providing
structure and web
applications.
So basically, Dart is a new
product that has a goal of
improving the productivity
of web developers.
And it can be used today.
You could download it
and try it out.
SETH LADD: So you mentioned
the web.
Kasper, where does Dart
actually run?
KASPER LUND: Actually it runs
across the entire modern web.
And so it runs in every
modern web browser.
And Dart can be translated to
modern JavaScript and it runs
just beautifully in
all new browsers.
Even we do have builds of
Dart that runs with a
native .VM as well.
But I think the core of it
is that it really runs
everywhere.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Mobile and desktop?
KASPER LUND: Mobile
and desktop.
Yeah.
SETH LADD: Perfect.
So what's the latest
news on Dart?
What did we learn
here from I/O?
LARS BAK: Well, that's a lot of
stuff going around with us.
Well, first of all, about Dart
is getting faster and faster.
We have a virtual machine for
Dart and we are now clocking
twice the speed of JavaScript,
so this is very exciting.
Because one of the goals for
Dart is we have a very
[? efficient ?] limitation,
because if you have a faster
engine in the browser, you will
allow web applications
available to us to be more
innovative in doing
applications.
So we want more advanced
apps in the browser.
KASPER LUND: Everything about
applications and benchmarks
starting to make good use of
the extra juice they're
getting from Dart and it's fun
to see these benchmarks and
applications come to life and
people are really starting to
build new, cool things
on top of Dart.
SETH LADD: Some of the other
news that I heard is the Dart
language is stable.
Where are we with the
core libraries?
LARS BAK: The core libraries
are also stable.
SETH LADD: Great.
LARS BAK: So the latest release
in 4 we had with Dart,
we really stopped further
development
with the core library.
So they're very consistent now
and you can pick it up and use
it in a consistent way.
And all the small pieces in
the libraries are fitting
together nicely.
So we're very proud of that.
KASPER LUND: Yeah, you
don't have to worry
about breaking changes.
Like if you build something on
top of the Dart platform now
using the libraries and the
language, they will run
tomorrow, as well.
SETH LADD: Great.
Well, I know that you've both
worked on a lot of virtual
machines before.
Tell us something that's
different or
unique now with Dart.
LARS BAK: Well, first of all,
this is the first time we're
doing a programming language.
And since we had all this
experience in implementing
programming languages, it's been
nice to be on both sides
of the fence.
We can do the design of the
programming language while
thinking about how we perform
when we implemented it.
So Dart has been designed
to be simple.
And yet, we could still optimize
it when we implement
it in a virtual machine.
KASPER LUND: It's really built
from the ground up based on
principles and designs that we
knew we could make run really
efficiently.
And we are starting to see that
come to life with that
factor of two on certain
benchmarks and applications.
So it's really nice.
SETH LADD: And you guys,
speaking of speed, you showed
a really cool demo in your
talk this morning.
Tell us a little bit about that
and how you're able to
unlock even more performance.
KASPER LUND: Well,
I can do that.
The demo we showed at the
session we had this morning
was showing that Dart is capable
of taking advantage of
what is know as SIMD
instructions found in most
modern CPUs.
And so syndi-instructions are
instructions that allow you to
operate on four floating point
values and parallel.
Making essentially three
new calculations and
audio-processing and stuff like
that, much, much faster.
So the demo we showed, had a
SMDI version and a non-SMDI
version and the SMDI version was
running some 3D animation
like four times faster.
It was really--
SETH LADD: Four times?
That's awesome.
Very cool.
So who's using Dart
these days?
We haven't quite hit 1.0, but is
anyone actually doing this?
LARS BAK: Well, people inside
Google and outside Google are
using Dart now, which
is great.
So, you have companies like
Blossom doing a lot of web
view component development
and also
providing back to the community.
So we have a site where people
can upload their packages.
SETH LADD: Help.dartlang.org
LARS BAK: Yeah.
And so other parties
can use it.
So this is very exciting and we
see a lot of traction this
year on Dart.
People are happy about
it and they seem
productive when using it.
KASPER LUND: I guess that's
the most important thing.
People actually trying the
platform out and using it to
build real things feel very,
very empowered by it and
productive.
That's awesome.
SETH LADD: I know there's other
partners that are using
and integrating Dart.
WebStorm IntelliJ.
They have a Dart plug-in,
for instance.
And then today we saw Adobe
announce their FlashPro
exports to Dart.
That's really cool to see these
other products and APIs
also playing in the
Dart ecosystem.
KASPER LUND: Yeah, that's very
nice to see them being able to
make use of the fact that
we run across the
entire modern web.
So you can take that code
generated from the Adobe tools
and you can compile it further
to JavaScript that runs
everywhere.
Or you could make use of the
Dart VM and get a fantastic
performance.
It works really well.
LARS BAK: So I just want to
add that Dart is an open
source project.
And we have many external
contributors to this project
and this is great.
That also allows other companies
like Adobe to
provide input to us or even
change the code itself, if
they choose to do so.
SETH LADD: So how do developers
get started?
Do I have to learn a whole
new programming language?
I mean, what happens there?
LARS BAK: Well, the good
thing about Dart is we
didn't invent very much.
So it's basically a very simple
program language, so if
you have a background in
JavaScript, C# or Java, you
can pick it up within an
hour, I would say.
KASPER LUND: So all you need to
do is to go to our website,
dartlang.org and download
a build of the
editor and off you go.
It's actually very easy
to get started.
SETH LADD: Great.
I want to go back to the
virtual machine aspect.
I know you guys have done
a lot of VMs from Java,
SmallTalk, V8, as well
and now Dart.
I'm still curious about what are
some of the design aspects
of the Dart language
that enables
the VM to be so efficient?
What's really the difference?
LARS BAK: Well, the easiest way
to explain it is by making
the contrast to JavaScript.
In JavaScript you can
add properties on
the fly to an update.
That basically means, ahead of
time, you don't know the
format of updates.
In Dart, we have designed it
so that when you create an
instance of a class, you know
exactly the format.
That means that they don't
change the layout of an
update, adjacent
to the program.
That makes it much easier to
generate code for fetching
fields and also takes
a [? cued ?]
method from that update.
KASPER LUND: And we actually
see a very big
benefit from that.
If you look at the generated
native code that the virtual
machine produces, it's
a lot smaller.
It's like a factor of three
smaller than the corresponding
code generated from V8, which
is a pretty good indication
that we're doing something
right.
Like aiming for this more
simple internal
structure of the VM.
And that really helps
performance.
LARS BAK: Another
thing we're also
looking at is quick start-up.
So when you contrast again
JavaScript to Dart, when you
read in JavaScript program,
you actually execute
JavaScript before you start
running the real program.
In Dart it's different.
You don't execute anything
before the first instruction
in main is being executed.
That allows us to apply
techniques like snapshotting
to get ultra fast start-up.
SETH LADD: And that's
incredibly
important on mobile.
Where every battery matters.
Definitely.
KASPER LUND: We're seeing this
technology where you can get
snaps of an entire application
and read it and start it up
really, really quickly.
Being super, super important
on mobile, definitely.
SETH LADD: And especially, if
you think about it, some
applications they have
a meg of JavaScript.
So imagine parsing in
that much text, just
to get the app running.
LARS BAK: On our benchmark, you
see that using snapshot
will make startup
10 times faster.
That means you only spend a
tenth of the energy when
loading in the application.
Which is great on mobile.
SETH LADD: Especially here
at a conference.
When your battery is
going to run out.
I want my web apps to be fast.
But this is a lot about
the virtual machine.
What are we doing Dart to JS?
To help keep those apps fast
even when we compile the
JavaScript?
KASPER LUND: So one of the
things that we do in Dart to
JS, is we built a fairly
advanced calculation
infrastructure that allows us
to do proper optimizations
while we compile Dart
to JavaScript.
So we do tree-shaking, where we
remove unused parts of your
code and we do things like
inline and constant folding,
and all the sort of classical
optimizations you do on code.
That means that if you write
Dart code, we can generate
reasonably efficient JavaScript
code that can
actually compete with
handwritten JavaScript code in
a lot of cases.
And we're very much focused on
delivering small JavaScript
code, as well.
So we built in a support for
minifying the output, so that
commonly used identifiers in
your code gets translated to
smaller, shorter identifiers.
That really helps a lot
on the code side.
So it's built into the tool and
it's kind of nice that as
a developer, you don't have
to worry about that.
SETH LADD: I want the tool
to do it for me, frankly.
KASPER LUND: Exactly.
LARS BAK: Just to stress a
point, we are not trying to
break the web platform
with Dart.
The whole point is that even
though we don't have Dart in
your browser, you can
still use it.
So you can translate Dart to
JavaScript and use it on an
existing browser without
the Dart VM.
And I think that's
pretty cool.
SETH LADD: That's incredibly
important.
KASPER LUND: One of the examples
of that is actually
the Dart's JS, the compiler
that translates Dart to
JavaScript is actually written
in Dart itself.
And it can actually translate
itself to JavaScript.
And the JavaScript that it
translates to can actually run
on any modern browser.
It can run on your iPad.
And that doesn't have
a Dart VM at all.
So just the fact that you have
Dart that can actually
translate to JavaScript that
runs across the entire mobile
and desktop web, is very, very
important to us and very, very
cool at the same time.
SETH LADD: Well certainly
performance
is incredibly important.
We saw what happened when V8
came along and started a new
renaissance performance and I
started to see what the Dart
VM and the Dart tools
are out there.
But there's a whole other
pillar in productivity.
You talked a little bit about
how Dart enables developers to
be more happy and productive,
as well.
LARS BAK: Well, Dart
is more structured.
That means that you can
have tools that
can analyze the program.
And you can have tools that
help you be organized to
program, like refactoring
of code.
We also have static types
you can use if
you want to in Dart.
And it allows you to have
more structured codes.
So for instance, if you have
two different development
teams that have to collaborate
on libraries, you can put in
types on the interfaces to the
library, so people could see
exactly what the intent is
in using the libraries.
I think that improves
productivity because you don't
have to go through a lot of
documentation to figure out
what's going on.
You don't have to dive
into the code.
You can look at the interface
and you convince yourself this
is the intended usage
of this library.
KASPER LUND: Now that you
mention library, one of the
other key points to boosting
productivity is also having
good support for modularity.
And Dart has that built in
as part of the language.
So that makes it very easy to
share pieces of functionality
and re-use pieces of
functionality, which makes you
more efficient, as
a programmer.
SETH LADD: Well, this
brings back to
the Pub package manager.
We've seen countless number of
packages where people have
shared their new libraries and
behavior and functionality and
the ecosystem grows.
KASPER LUND: I think we're
seeing more than 200 packages
on the Pub page at this point
and it's certainly growing by
the minute, basically.
LARS BAK: It makes me
happy to see the
communities pick this up.
This is exactly what we intended
with this platform.
Programmers need choice when
doing web development and I
think that is a good
alternative.
And if it makes some programmers
more productive,
you've succeeded basically.
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
So what does the future
hold for Dart?
What can we expect to come up?
LARS BAK: Well, should
I take that?
KASPER LUND: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
LARS BAK: So first of all, we
are going to ship the Dart SDK
1.0, here after summer.
And we're excited about that,
we have a complete package.
At the same time, we are taking
the program language
Dart, and putting into
the standards body.
Hopefully.
It's in the process.
And then we'll work really,
really hard to get into
Chrome, as the next step.
So it's really exciting.
And when it gets into Chrome,
you'll see this VM speed up
when you have your existing
Dart application.
And that's exciting.
Suddenly everything
runs faster.
SETH LADD: That's right.
It runs across the web, if you
happen to have the VM it's
like an accelerator.
LARS BAK: Exactly.
KASPER LUND: And clearly
we're not done with a
performance work yet.
We can do even better.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
see the numbers are we're
not even at 1.0 yet.
KASPER LUND: It looks good, but
it can get even better.
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
So Dart's an open
source project.
You could participate on
GitHub and Google Code.
And we ask you guys to go to
dartlang.org, download the SDK
and the editor.
And join the project, see
what you can build.
We look forward to seeing
what you build with us.
Thanks everyone.
LARS BAK: Thanks.